pienso que todos estamos ciegos
somos ciegos que pueden ver pero que no
miran josé saramago ensayo sobre la
ceguera
yo era un ciego hasta que vi por primera
vez mi reflejo en la basura
todavía recuerdo ese primer día cuando
me llevaron por cuestiones de trabajo a
un tiradero municipal
ver esa cantidad de camiones vomitando
literalmente bolsas de basura fue algo
que marcó mi vida y por supuesto mi
olfato
creo que hay noches todavía donde me
despierto con ese olor que la verdad es
que es muy difícil de explicar no sé si
alguno de ustedes alguna vez lo haya
olido
pero lo que más me impresionó de ese
momento fue cuando voltea al piso y
viene el piso una botella de champú
desde champú de la misma marca de la que
yo usaba
y pensé eso podría haber salido de mi
casa esa esa es mi basura
muchas cosas pasaron por supuesto por mi
cabeza desde cómo es posible que
generemos tal cantidad de residuos
porque lo seguimos acumulando en sitios
inadecuados y qué impacto tiene esto en
la salud humana en el medio ambiente y
en la calidad de vida de las personas
dice el banco mundial que cada uno de
nosotros genera 1.16 kilos de basura
todos los días si pensamos que tenemos
una esperanza de vida de 70 años
aproximadamente en esos 70 años habremos
vivido 25 mil quinientos días en ese
tiempo en toda nuestra vida habremos
generado un total de 30 toneladas de
basura un contenedor como el que ven
ustedes ahí
ahora multiplicamos lo por los 7500
millones de personas que viven hoy en
este planeta o por los 9 mil millones
que van a vivir al 2050
quienes trabajamos en tema de turismo
sabemos que el tema de los residuos se
vuelve todavía más complicado
probablemente porque cuando el turista
viaja se relaja seguramente a ustedes
les pasa comen más consumen más y por
ende generan mucho más residuos o porque
probablemente como administradores de
destinos e incluso gestores de empresas
nos pasamos la vida tratando de
satisfacer con productos y servicios que
generan residuos satisfactores y
necesidades que probablemente el turista
ni siquiera sabía que existía
necesitamos mirar más y dejar de ver
me gustaría llevarlos en un ejercicio
para identificar todo aquello que
generamos en el momento en que hacemos
un viaje
por ejemplo si su pase de abordar no es
electrónico que hoy es la tendencia
seguramente se los van a imprimir en
papel en un papel que además es un papel
encerado que es bien difícil de poder
reciclar o reutilizar
cuando llegamos al destino generalmente
nos ofrecen folletos o mapas qué pasa
con todo eso cuando termina su vida útil
a dónde va cómo lo estamos gestionando
seguramente cuando llegan a nuestro
hotel o cuando empezamos las actividades
turísticas nos regalan un cóctel de
bienvenida
cual quieren ustedes que es la vida útil
de esa página que está en ese vaso 5
minutos 2
tal vez 1 y saben cuánto tiempo va a
tardar en degradarse eso en el medio
ambiente probablemente cientos de años
por supuesto cuando llegamos a nuestra
instalación turística hay que refrescar
nos venimos cansados necesitamos darnos
una ducha
champú de esa ducha viene botellita de
plástico y se los van a cambiar todos
los días y el jabón que usan también
viene envuelto en plástico
probablemente ya estas alturas ya nos
tomamos tres o cuatro botellas de agua
porque por supuesto nuestros amigos pero
también el touroperador nuestro agente
de viajes la gente del hotel el taxista
nos dijo mucho cuidado con tomar agua
local
a donde terminan todas esas botellas que
al final de cuentas se vuelven un
residuo que estamos generando nosotros
como turistas
nos dio hambre vamos a comer
el restaurante ofrece servicio de buffet
les quiero dar un dato el 50 por ciento
de toda la comida que se prepara para
montar un buffet se desperdicia ya sea
porque como turistas lo servimos demás y
dejamos cosas en el plato o porque las
instalaciones turísticas no tienen la
capacidad y no hay los protocolos para
poder aprovechar esos estos alimentos
que terminan yéndose cuando bien nos va
a una composta o si no a estos tiraderos
de verdad que ciegos estamos
dicen que el cambio climático es uno de
los mayores retos que tenemos como
sociedad y por supuesto en los destinos
turísticos y en especial en estos donde
vivimos que son islas o que son destinos
costeros y la verdad es que a mí me
preocupa mucho menos el aumento del
nivel del mar estoy realmente inquieto
porque vayamos a quedar ahogados en
nuestra propia basura ya sea la que
producimos nosotros o la que llega a
nuestras costas nos ha atacado
participar en limpiezas de playa donde
el 80% de los residuos que sacamos de
esas playas no son producidos en el país
es más ni siquiera son usados por los
turistas que llegan a estos sitios
como avanzamos entonces en estos temas
cómo hacemos para generar una dinámica
en la cual nosotros como ciudadanos
nosotros como turistas nosotros como
empresarios le entremos fuerte y
decididamente a este tema de los
residuos nada porque no les he contado
pero en el tema de residuos sólidos hay
muchas estadísticas en especial una de
la unión europea que dice que el turista
produce dos veces más de residuos que la
persona que vive en un destino turístico
y por supuesto que el turista no se
lleva su basura a su casa si se le
llevará seguramente le cobrarían exceso
de equipaje eso que generan ellos más lo
que generamos nosotros se queda aquí y
en esta zona especialmente es un tema
complejo porque además estamos en una
isla y no podemos sacar la basura a otro
sitio
necesitamos empezar a mirar mucho más y
no tan solo a ver necesitamos empezar a
tomar una verdadera responsabilidad en
el manejo de los residuos porque en este
caso en el de los residuos como en
muchos otros casos donde nosotros
trabajamos con temas de sostenibilidad
hay una frase que se nos debe de quedar
tatuada todos somos corresponsables o lo
que es lo mismo peca tanto el que mata
la vaca como el que le agarra la pata
es decir del productor de insumos pero
también el diseñador del hotel el
diseñador de experiencias la comunidad
local la municipalidad y el mismo
turista somos corresponsables de este
problema que no es un problema mínimo y
la verdad es que no importa si ya vamos
viviendo en este destino 40 años o 20 o
un día o venimos solamente de paso la
responsabilidad en este tema tiene que
ser una responsabilidad de todos
como actuamos entonces que hacemos
nosotros que al final de cuentas estamos
ofreciendo un servicio estamos teniendo
un beneficio pero probablemente estamos
teniendo mucho más costos asociados a
este beneficio que tenemos necesitamos
empezar a mirar mucho más y necesitamos
empezar a pensar cómo construimos
comunidad e identidad a través del
turismo
los últimos 15 años de mi vida me he
pasado visitando sitios turísticos y en
todos absolutamente todos la visión es
la misma que el turismo sea una
herramienta para conservar los recursos
naturales que sea una herramienta para
el desarrollo local y que sea una
herramienta para construcción de
identidad desgraciadamente muchas veces
esa visión no se logra porque porque no
generamos comunidad porque seguimos
pensando que cada uno de nosotros es una
persona que tiene responsabilidades como
persona y no vemos las responsabilidades
que tenemos comunes
en el tema de la generación de residuos
como en el tema en otros temas
relacionados con sostenibilidad
necesitamos empezar a construir mucha
más comunidad de la que tenemos ahora y
la gran pregunta es cómo construimos esa
identidad cómo construimos esa comunidad
cuando nosotros empezamos a mirar mucho
más y a ver menos nos damos cuenta que
nuestro impacto es un impacto que puede
ser minimizado pero que también tenemos
una gran responsabilidad con el que
llega a vivir o de turista de mostrarle
estos impactos y de involucrarlo en la
resolución de hechos
cuando nosotros por ejemplo dejamos de
usar vajillas o cuando nosotros
localmente creamos una ley para eliminar
como ha pasado en muchos destinos el uso
de plásticos de un solo uso estamos
construyendo identidad
cuando nos organizamos localmente y
entonces logramos hacer la limpieza de
playas más grandes de nuestro destino
pero incluso cuando nosotros recogemos
la basura de enfrente de nuestra casa y
de la casa de nuestros vecinos estamos
construyendo identidad cuando nosotros
trabajamos para involucrar a una
comunidad local a que nos resuelva un
problema de reciclaje como por ejemplo
el de los jabones de los hoteles y
entonces ese trabajo genera que
realmente esta comunidad resuelve un
problema y tengo un beneficio estamos
construyendo también identidad cuando
tomamos ejemplos como el del chef
italiano massimo bottura que seguramente
conocen que se dedica en los grandes
eventos a tomar todo el desperdicio de
comida para hacer cenas de lujo para
personas vulnerables con una intención
con una doble intención la primera de
darle de comer bien a alguien que no
puede comer bien todos los días pero la
segunda de hacer conciencia que tal vez
o que no es ok o nosotros llamamos
desperdicio no necesariamente
cuando nosotros tomamos estos ejemplos
localmente estamos construyendo también
identidad
el tema de los residuos como muchos
otros temas relacionados con la
sustentabilidad se debe de abordar desde
una perspectiva local y necesitamos
empezar a ser más activos en estos
procesos porque de otra forma estos
mismos procesos nos van a ahogar
cuando nosotros construimos identidad a
través de esta resolución efectiva de
conflictos no tan solo estamos tomando
nuestra responsabilidad global como
ciudadanos y comunidad y estamos
generando acciones locales que realmente
resuelven el problema cuando nosotros
hacemos comunidad lo que en realidad
estamos haciendo es que estamos
generando un mejor lugar para vivir
un mejor lugar para convivir y un mejor
lugar para poder mirarnos a los ojos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]